non-minimalists
how should i go about combating
roommates or
friends of roommates who steal my
material items such as
food or money or self-care so chris
let's
let's rephrase gwen's question here
basically say how do i appropriately set
boundaries with
the people in my community or in my home
or whatever to ensure those boundaries
are
not crossed you want to prevent people
from stealing obviously
property damage but also just tense
living
situations right um now you live in a
can you talk a bit about your maybe your
communal situation
so we've experimented with a number of
different configurations over the past
year
ranging from like a time segmented
type arrangement where for a few days a
week we're living with another
family so i've got two kids one who's a
girl who's seven
and a boy who's three and we've spent
time living under the same roof
with another couple who have kids of
similar ages
they have uh so we've lived with a
number of different families but
i think they've all had two kids about
the same ages now what have you learned
from living with these different
families because
you uh gwen's question here is you
basically have introduced roommates
what we mean in our today society would
say roommates it's different from that
but that's how you even have to classify
it it's almost it's euphemistic right
there was a time not too long ago when
gay couples used to have to say they had
roommates
as opposed to having a partner or a
husband or
and and so now you are trying these sort
of experiments
uh with other families living together
um how did you
why did you start doing this i think
the kids were actually the main driver
um i did a
podcast interview with peter gray who
you might might know his uh he's got a
really great book
called free to learn okay and peter
talked about
the common word is unschooling yes i
don't really like that term
peter doesn't like it either because it
focuses on what you're not doing
versus what you are doing so perhaps a
better description
is non-coercive self-directed learning
meaning you're trusting the kids to find
the best learning opportunity
on their own without you doing much of
anything and
in order for that to work you need older
kids right i don't care how old your kid
is you need an older kid
because the older kid is like the
scaffolding that helps the younger kid
up to the next level
so you're not doing the teaching the
older kids are doing the teaching
you know so i've seen this happen
firsthand where you've got an older kid
that can read
and they're looking at words on a screen
or a piece of paper and they're telling
the younger kid what they say so the
older kid is actually teaching
the younger kid even though the older
kid doesn't know what they're doing yeah
and in that teaching
he or she is also learning through the
problem you learn so much more by
teaching than
than just about any other way exactly
and so the problem is like you can't do
that with just two kids right like you
need more kids than that and so the
question then becomes where do you get
more kids
now we live in a very rural area where
most of the houses are on very large
lots
and so there are some kids around in the
neighborhood but not
enough and so we needed to do something
to bring more kids in
and that's exactly what we've been able
to do and it's been great
well let's talk a bit a bit more about
that um when you say it's been great it
sounds like you've lived with several
different families
explain that yeah so we've done a couple
of different things we've had people
living in our house
so we live in quite a small house it's
about 1200 square foot
and uh you know that's not very much
space when you've got two families
living under the same roof
we've also done other things like having
people bring on a trailer like these tra
i don't know if you've seen them but
these travel trailers are tremendous
value for money you can get
like a house that's nicer than our house
for
you know twenty thousand dollars or
something and you can move it you can
just roll it on to so we're lucky that
we live on quite a large property
we've had people bring on a trailer and
use that as a sort of separate space
from the main house that can definitely
get a little bit crazy at times
and and so how do you navigate these
relationships because these
different people have different desires
different ones different preferences
different hobbies
uh different levels of tolerance and and
different desires
how do you navigate all of that well i
think you start by
having similar value systems right so
ancestral health is
super important to us and it gives us
some guiding principles
that we operate by and like finding
people that share those values like i
could live with you it'd be great
because i know you eat the same food
you go to bed at the same time i think
we could we share a lot of things in
common
and so it's not that much work to try
and close the gap you know
um so i heard once a lawyer told me that
that sometimes a case will go to
mediation and the judge will just refuse
to do anything they won't
try and close the gap because it's just
too big like there's too much distance
between the two sides and they say go
away just go sue yourself
you know go sue each other because this
is not a gap i can close
and i think the same is true with like
communal living like you need to
find people that share your value system
so that whenever conflict does arise
there's like not that much of a gap to
close and so
and that is indeed what we've been doing
so all of the people we've lived with
have had very similar value systems ryan
it sounds like
obviously the the thing that um
the best way to deal with conflict
within the house to get back to gwen's
question here
is to screen the roommates beforehand
right right i think back to
relationships that i've had
whether friendship or into intimate
relationships
quite often it's simply a screening
problem because chris said like
we don't have the same values of course
there's good with that greater gap
means there's going to be greater
tension between the two of us yeah
yeah i mean when it comes to gwen's
question i would
you know ask her is there a way to close
that gap with
with her roommates and with her
roommate's friends it sounds like yeah
um
if it's not possible i mean she could
certainly do things like
i don't know when i had roommates i
would lock my door
um i didn't it didn't get to the point
where i had a
where i had to get like my own mini
fridge because uh that gap
with the particular roommate you know
who i'm talking about oh yeah
um i will uh not name him to
not shame him publicly yeah exactly
but you know if i couldn't move out and
if i couldn't afford it to have moved
out like it would have come to that
situation where i would have had to
spend like a couple hundred bucks to get
my own mini fridge
right um yeah so uh yeah if the gap is
too
large gwen she's gotta move out
it's really rough it's very different
from my situation like everyone we've
lived with
has been tremendously respectful like
overly cautious of anything you know
what it's like when you
move in with a partner and it's kind of
intimidating right like you're moving
into their space and you tread really
lightly
and you're just very respectful that's
more similar to my
situation versus living in college with
a bunch of
[ __ ] roommates that are like fine
about taking your food and
yeah like that's a very different
situation i think so but even then you
have you have conflict right
and so there'll be times where maybe you
don't agree on a parenting
thing yeah and how does that work out uh
that actually ended
one uh one yeah you're right like here
we go now we're getting into the drama
the juicy stuff yeah i thought so i
don't have a parenting style
um that's actually peter gray talked
about that in my podcast as well like
hunter-gatherers don't do parenting and
they don't do teaching either
and you know i've read some really good
books on this alison gopnik the
carpenter and the gardener is a really
good one
and i love that metaphor it's like so
relevant for
dealing with complex systems you know
wearing carpentry you measure twice and
you cut once and it's like building a
dining room table and it's very obvious
when the job is done
and you know you test to see if it
wobbles and all this stuff and then
maybe you make some
you know slight refinements and in the
end you've got this perfectly crafted
piece of furniture
whereas in gardening it's mostly about
keeping the weeds out and just creating
an environment for the
for the plants to flourish and you never
really know what you're going to get you
know i mean of course you know what
seeds you put in the ground but you
don't really know what's going to grow
right and so what alison gottnick is
arguing is that
parenting is more like gardening and
less like carpentry
but a lot of people they treat it like
carpentry and that
in the beginning i thought i don't care
you know it's fine if like if you want
to do helicopter parenting go ahead and
helicopter
but i mean i don't have a style so i
should be compatible with any style but
you're right it like once they start
helicoptering your kids
it's like oh [ __ ] like i can't handle
this and so that actually did end
one relationship so give me examples of
of helicoptering
what does that look like in in the real
world uh
i mean it looks exactly what it sounds
like it's you you
you you're literally hovering over the
child micromanaging their every move
and the way it would like i know it's
happening even if i'm not paying
attention
is like i would hear the kid's name over
and over again like over and over again
you're like wait why is
why is the person using the kid's name
over and over again
it's because they're constantly trying
to direct them towards the next it's
control yeah it's overly controlling now
what what about that control is so
appealing to us
i don't know it's like i think one thing
i think is going on in silicon valley is
people are really struggling with
purpose
you know they do you know like there's
this kind of standing joke that the
the brightest minds in the world are all
working in silicon valley getting people
to click on stuff right
yeah all these people with phds and
stuff like just getting people to click
on stuff
and it's it's not it's not really
scratching people's itch you know it's
not like a
great purpose and i think it's a really
common thing for
people to either quit their job or um
you know this is what they do as a hobby
like they go all in on parenting you
know like
it becomes a new obsession yeah exactly
i think a lot of the helicopter
parenting too probably spawns from good
intentions
you know like maybe you're just trying
to protect your kid from not getting
hurt
and there is a there's a balance there
right but yeah if you're constantly
hovering over them you're not allowing
them to flourish themselves
yeah exactly exactly good intentions and
bad ideas jonathan heights book the
coding of the american mind explains the
whole thing very well i think
yeah and i think if we we back up and
remove ourselves from even the parenting
situation the same thing can happen with
roommates or or significant others
spouses whatever
we can become helicopter partners we can
become
you know helicopter roommates and and it
quickly becomes an
untenable situation and so it's
fascinating to me when we're talking
about communal
living really what you're talking about
isn't a traditional
commune necessarily but it's maybe an
iteration
of that what do you mean by commune well
what do you what what image is that
conjure when i say commune
uh it conjures up images wild wild
country that was actually i
lied i said i don't watch tv we did
watch that on there yes it was really
good i really enjoyed that so yeah i
think of gurus
like it scares the hell out of me you
know like somebody a boss like
no but it sounds to me like often those
intentions of
because here's the thing we hear about
wild wild country or we hear about
nexium or whatever these these cults
right and there are so many that you
don't hear about because they're
actually just communes that are working
fine and there isn't some sex
crazed leader who is making the news
it just happens to be that they're we
hear about the salacious stuff right
and so we hear about when people are
drinking kool-aid and killing themselves
and
or or joining some sort of cult that
castrates
each other or whatever it is that stuff
makes the news
you know it doesn't make the news four
families decide to live together happily
exactly lived happily ever after it's
not a great news story is it
no and so um i don't know do you see
this evolving
over time as you get acclimated with
different families or whatever do you
see
a larger group forming out of this
potentially well that's an interesting
question is it how much is enough
this is a very interesting question yeah
we've yet to figure out what the ideal
number is so i know that things get
way better and my motivation to go find
the others goes
exponentially down as we add more people
so even one other couple
and their kids is so much better than
just the nuclear family in my opinion
how many uh families are living on your
property right now so at the moment
so we were in a relationship with
another couple that's going really well
and they've got
two kids who are 11 and just turned
seven
and then we've got another neighbor who
has a four-year-old girl who recently
put a trailer on our property
and she's more like sort of the time
segmented thing you know where she'll
come for a couple of days a week
cool and that's i mean so far so good
like it's it's really new but
so far so good awesome i want to talk
about your sleeping situation
on the maximal episode but we have uh we
have some more to get into
gwen i'm going to send you a copy of the
minimalist rule book
because one thing we didn't talk about
but it should be self-evident at this
point
is boundaries now the first boundary is
before you even let the roommate into
the house right until you the first
boundary is not coming to an agreement
with someone who
has complete opposite values with you
you know
you're setting yourself up for
discontent
for quote unquote failure for tension
etc
uh property damage whatever like there's
going to be all kinds of
of things you don't want to get involved
in but even then like ryan and i have
the same values
we don't always agree on things in fact
he and i have lived together before
we've had different
preferences and sometimes that just
dictates
i think what what really helped ryan and
i live together was kind of what
chris was saying is like we we didn't
just tolerate each other we respected
each other's
desires yes and in that respect
even if i don't completely understand it
i can completely appreciate
you know the way that you live and vice
versa you're not harming me or anyone
else yeah we were totally
capable of telling each other if
something was
bugging us or something our preferences
were being stepped on maybe
yeah it was very simple to just have a
conversation and
i mean that might just spawn from i
think we have an exceptional
an exceptional relationship in that
sense where like we can deliver
the truth to each other in a way even if
it
sounds negative like we don't take it
negatively we just kind of take it
for what it is yes and uh yeah i mean
that's i think that's unfortunately a
rare thing in relationships but i think
the closer
people can get to that in their
relationships to not be offended when
someone's like hey i'd really appreciate
it if you
x y or z um yeah that would create some
better living situations for sure yeah i
found five words that are really useful
for me as well um would you be willing
to
would you be willing to shut up
but instead of like hey man how come you
always leave your uh
salt crumbs on the counter yeah hey
would you be willing to clean those
up yeah it just it this not a
patronizing way but hey
you know would you be willing to and and
those have disarmed so many arguments
in my life but also it shows a just a
common respect and i think another way
to show respect is to set boundaries up
so
we have the minimalist rule book it's 16
rules for living with
less you can download it for free over
at the minimalists.com
rulebook also the audiobook version is
available there as well
or you can get the free ebook there just
download it the minimalists dot com
slash
rulebook